on this episode I'm super super super
excited because of a Jets win and I get
really really really deep
[Music]
Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 1 38 of
the ask gary vee show i am in a very
good mood period as my New York trip
actually you know what's really fun this
is really fun stuff on by the way step
on let's show stuff on try to get some
ladies out of this stuff on is editing
the show now d-roc you don't get the the
shriek ready rock working on some of the
bigger projects to find getting in the
zone helps us get the show out a little
bit soon or too so I think you guys are
benefiting from Stefan's elevation into
this spot what I want to do on Mondays
regardless of how worked out or not is
play the clip maybe 15 seconds 8 seconds
I'll try not to drag them out of my
official prediction so we can see so
obviously you just heard that have in
real time so obviously I made this
prediction this Sunday the Jets go out
and beat the Cleveland Browns who have
not won an opener since I think 2004 19
to 7 not bad 19 to 731 10 not super bad
12 and 3.5 it's gonna get way worse than
that and I'm excited I'm heading to
Indianapolis I'm going to a wedding this
weekend in Denver area and then I'll be
flying back connecting the home I'm
really tough travel to get into India
late late Sunday night and in time for
the Jets Monday night game against the
closest of my third trip to Indianapolis
for a football game both other games
were playoff games we won one we lost
one we lost the one that would have got
us into the Super Bowl we won a
first-round game that was a good one
though so one to beat Peyton Manning in
his last game as a Colt saying Colt fans
and so a great great mood really pumped
that up Malden is okay we had a player
that looked like really seriously
injured completely put a cloud on my day
I'm pumped to see you're okay Lorenzo
good luck feel better Antonio Cromartie
a friend and a great jet looks pretty
heard news in a couple hours but I'm
fearing that he's out for a year but
otherwise a tremendous day this cute
little picture with me and AJ I'm
Instagram and stunwin listen to the game
he's clearly luck
claims to me yeah first game over listen
to me what happened I'm excited we'll
see what happens we continue congrats to
everybody one sorry to everybody who
lost Giants and uh and let's hope Jets
football let's get into the show
someone oh video right off the bat he's
doing a lot of video today hey this is
John meek
by reaching out to you from Toronto
Ontario my question for you to regard to
my father-in-law's business my
father-in-law is from Minsk Belarus
originally so his English is very poor
he moved here about three years ago but
he's an amazing fantastic contractor and
he wants to grow his business and I want
to help him so given the scope of let's
say about $1,000 because we're really
small what are some baby steps you could
suggest to me as a marketer of his
business to do so I can help them out so
we can start getting some traction here
you keep answering our questions Gary
and I promise we'll keep asking thanks
for everything you do John great
question obviously you know how to hit
my emotional center by going back to the
old country and and that's a great great
question and a real practical one
thousand dollars I think is really so
much more realistic for a lot of people
that listen way more than the clients
that we have here at Vayner spending
hundreds of thousands millions of
dollars each month in different
marketing activities a couple different
things number one I noticed you said a
heavy accent which made me believe that
you were alluding to don't give me the
advice to put him on camera or put him
out there now if his personality is like
my mom's who never shows up I actually
asked my mom for the first time at the
Jets game yesterday I said mom I think
it might be time for you to be on the
show and make your first-ever appearance
she said no she really it's just not her
thing and so that crushed my heart mom
and you crushed the entire Vayner
nation's heart mom they all want you to
me on the show so now if his accent is
something you're worried about but he's
willing to do content and become Bob
Vila which you know I know you're in
Canada but I think Vila might be an
international star right but if you
don't know it is look it up you became
like the home if he became America's
contractor in the 80s on PBS when people
weren't doing the kind of con
don't we see on cable these days when
chefs and real estate agents became
famous and so I would put I would make
videos of him if he's that great of a
contractor I believe you I think you
know you get different skills from
different parts of the world he'll bring
a little that Eastern European Flair or
or soundness or whatever that angle is
to the Canadian building market I think
you put them on and start doing Bob Vila
like videos now with a thousand dollars
I would spend that on the 10 15 20 30
mile radius of your guys area to get
those videos out to people that are fans
of things like Architectural Digest or
things that are into building and and
interior design into the culture of home
building contract work renovations
things of that nature so now if he's not
willing to go on camera because he's
introverted or shy worried about his
accent I know a lot of those variables
you need to figure out how to make
content that is compelling to people
maybe you translate his advice into
written form and then you run ads on
Facebook in a 20-mile radius did you
know you can fix cabinets by doing this
replacing new floors and you got to
target people based on interests that
may find that interesting content is the
gateway drug for small businesses that
don't have a lot of money have to put
out great content spend a little dollars
just like I did with Wine Library TV but
now there's more things Instagram
accounts those kind of things that's
what I would do Matt McLeod asks Gary
you talked about in your early years you
didn't say anything and just built your
brand how do you know when to switch to
the next level you know I think you know
listen there's a lot of people who never
switch who says you have to switch to
become an outward personality or you
want that I wanted that I love you know
Mom you'll like this cuz I know you're
watching now that I mentioned you and
you're paying extra attention you know
my mom loved me so much to such a high
level I feel that I'm a good guy because
I want the love and admiration from all
of you because I still want that feeling
I like that feeling it's crazy I'm
starting to really really understand
that that's what I'm like why am i why
do I even care to be a good guy they're
so easy not to it's cuz I really like
the feeling of being loved I mean just
it's super Sam there's only
one way to do that which is to provide
love first and so you know I think that
I'm making that I needed that I needed
to be out in the open mass love or
whatever I'm looking for but not
everybody needs them do you know how
many people for every Mark Cuban or
Richard Branson right for every one of
those kind of entrepreneurs that are out
there you know there are so many that
you've never heard of building hundred
there you don't meet people right now
have a hundred million dollar business a
five hundred million dollar business
that you've literally never heard of
countless don't look at Forbes fortune
400 400 richest people you'd be
flabbergasted how many of them you've
never heard of it
so you don't have to make the switch to
become a personal brand or be out there
um you know you know many people push
the other way who never want to be who
spend money actually to not be known
they just want to keep getting the money
it depends what drives you money is fine
but it's a byproduct of what drives me
which is building community creating a
legacy empowering people it's it's
equally selfish as it is you know Noble
and so I think first it starts with
knowing yourself and recognizing you
don't have to one could argue that if I
didn't need that I'd have a 500 million
dollar wine business right now so this
is not necessarily always about making
more money it's about checking the boxes
that make you happy
like going to a Jets game that makes me
very happy the community we love this
one hey there for three-dimensional Gary
I just want to know two things first of
all what are you gonna do with yourself
now that I'm taking over this [ __ ] oh
you see that do you Brock think of me to
cry but also what are some of the
biggest changes that have happened since
I came out with my book Jab Jab Jab
right hook great question great work
Steve want you to tell the story real
quick on how this amazing cartoon came
to fruition
oh I tweeted something about an obscure
video game from the 90s which won a game
called the Neverhood there's a
Kickstarter coming out
armored Krog and this random guy doesn't
like random guy was just like oh yeah
like I'm really excited for that to come
out to let me started going back and
forth and I followed him and all of a
sudden he made one of these like random
custom things and made a video saying
thanks for following me and I was like
this is ridiculous and Gary to make one
of Gary and he did and we ended up going
back and forth and he ended up asking
your question amazing I mean he jabbed
you you jabbed me I love it I love it
you know what Chrono Trigger is of
course
just want to show you what a lot of
things have changed since Jab Jab Jab
right hook cuz I matter fact as I was
writing it the paid volume of importance
on paid in facebook was happening as Jab
Jab Jab right hook was being ran and
organic organic reach was dropping I was
like oof and Instagram was becoming more
obvious to me as a main play which I
brought it to the front of the book you
know obviously Instagram now has paid
right now Pinterest I think I understand
better than I did when I wrote Japanese
abra hook mmm I would have done more
search engine process and understanding
for Pinterest snapchat would have become
enormous ly important part of Jab Jab
Jab Jab right hook to snapchat would be
at the forefront I would do more b2b
stuff I can understand that better and
would do more LinkedIn content YouTube
wasn't even a part of it I probably
would acknowledge it more and jam with
it so Facebook has become even more
important and more powerful I would
argue the Twitter's become less powerful
so yeah I mean that's the point right I
try to write but it's funny the new book
that's coming out March askgaryvee the
book is probably gonna be the most
evergreen book
I know Thank You economy isn't an
outrageously evergreen book but uh Jab
Jab right hook and crush it to a degree
I think you I mean all the books I write
tend to have that 24 to 48 month life
cycle and then I feel like they need
updating and so I put out a lot of free
content like I do here to to make sure
I'm providing value I take an enormous
responsibility for somebody who spent
$15 to buy my book
to bring them value I do that by
subsidizing a product like this for free
forever you see that look again with you
by the way Stefan should really have to
be in the filming of every episode I
recognized after the other day the jet
up is so like there's a disadvantage for
him not because all the subtle things
makes them have to pay attention way
more whereas here now he can either take
notes or mental notes it'll be a lot
easier just new rule alert Stefan that
was super meta that was really nice
Kyle Reed asks if Lizzie had a
successful business what would you do to
support and encourage her hmm
so supple wears is important I will say
this this is gonna be really interesting
to see how everybody handles this answer
uh as long as Lizzie's business was
smaller than mine
I would don't forget I'm I see the
following and I said all the time I want
to build the biggest building in town
I'm obsessed with it I do I want to do
that by building the biggest building in
town and I have no interest in tearing
down anybody else's business I would
100% struggle if Lizzie ran a business
and it was financially more successful
than mine it would absolutely [ __ ] II
just the truth and so the question
becomes I would help it with all my
heart and soul but god forbid
I even felt any indication that it was
about to pass whatever I was up to I
would pull out of there and then start
undermining it in weird ways to make
sure that wouldn't happen this is tough
right I mean it's just the truth I mean
I'm uh listen I married Lizzie because I
knew what I was looking for in a partner
in a spouse like but people change I
don't think Lizzie
maybe I've even realized how insanely
workaholic it would become I mean I
thought I was working a lot before so
things change it's interesting though I
will say this and this really is an
interesting part of the whole thing even
I'm fascinated by it there's a part of
me that's sad about what I'm better
saying I would be way better a
out it today then I would have been five
years ago I can feel it and it scares me
to think what I'd be willing to do maybe
even 10 or 15 years from now I feel like
it I feel like it's like a competitive
softening and I think it's true at least
with Lizzie not for any B's guys I gotta
I'd kill Stefan like physically dead you
know like you know so so um I that's the
truth I I would do as long as I felt
that it was not gonna be as big as my
businesses I would give her anything in
the world period but there is a very
dark competitive side to me when it
comes to business and I friends who have
much more successful businesses and it's
stunning to me how happy I am for them
like I wouldn't have thought that 20
years ago but it doesn't mean that I
don't think about every day beating them
and I want it badly I don't know if I'd
be able to handle that with a spouse
No yeah I just that's not what I was
looking for in a partner really I was
looking for somebody who really was CEO
of our family who could um somebody that
I didn't feel like I had I could I don't
I compete with everybody in the world
you know what kind of what a kind of
comfort zone my wife is for me like I
compete with everybody in the world
she's my teammate I don't want to be
forced by my own craziness to compete
with her so that's what happened yeah
yeah Real Talk
the show got real like I'm very
self-aware enough to know that's not
going to be the most politically correct
answer but um I take a lot of pride in
that this show is forced me to tell
truths all the way through and I really
hope nobody my family will ever watch
that answer no I think everybody think
everybody I you know I think everybody
you know what I don't know if I would
have answered this question in episode
20 you know I think I would have dodged
it if maybe even being I want to be I'm
going real raw now I probably would have
I would have danced a little bit more I
just feel at this point this collective
audience this could be your first
episode but this collective audience is
starting to really understand who I am
and that's just the truth I want to
write as I say it out loud I probably
answered it but let the chips fall the
truth is just always the best spot
alright lastly do you think that's what
was coming I don't know but it makes
sense I know tons of when couples are in
the same industry together that comes up
sure yeah like I just compete with
everything and everybody like like my my
dad my my siblings like I can already
feel it brewing with my children I just
need them Liz to me I just need one
partner is that is that why you went
into business with AJ because the idea
of him you know that's an interesting
it's an interesting question you know
what's funny I actually think AJ can
build bigger businesses than I can
because I think in the way he's wired
allows him to create a scale I see AJ
being much more capable to build a
$500.00 software 500 million dollar
software company I see AJ having the
kind of makeup especially now actually I
think the best way for me to have not
had AJ compete with me is to have never
gone into business with him because then
he would have never learned the things
that I've been teaching him and rounding
out that kind of the magic ray I think
he's now in a position to really give me
a run okay older brother you love yours
like trust me if I was the younger
brother I would be like no way getting
deep here on a Monday let's go chase hey
what's up here it's Chase Jarvis I got a
question man but one second first oh wow
photographer the director and I'm also
the CEO of creativeLIVE which is the
world's largest live-streaming education
company my question is about creativity
what role does creativity play in
business in the future of business
leadership and strategy please tell me
man I'm dying to know well chase let's
talk about strategy when you were a
Seattle Seahawks fan in the last 36
months and you decide to finally send
the video that we've been waiting for
for a year now on maybe the only Sunday
in the last 36 months on the Monday
after a Sunday where the Jets won and
the Seahawks lost I would argue if
somebody's nerdy about this please tell
me the other weekends others
I mean the Seahawks lost like two three
games a year for Lester so maybe
serendipitously but there is probably
the likelihood of 1648 you know a $0.48
Mondays shows after Sunday's there was
probably three maybe two that had this
situation what they that we had
yesterday where you put on a Seahawks
Jersey and diss the Jets right like that
makes me so happy that your timing is so
off strategy that you so poorly planned
the strategy of this video it makes me
happy with that move that you just
pulled creative strategy I forgot the
question I blacked out with the Jets
anything what role does give me the
punchline and we play a Stefon my
question is about creativity what role
does creativity play in business in the
future of business leadership and
strategy please tell me man I'm dying to
know
I mean chase first personal an amazing
guy every photographer watching this
should watch every entrepreneur should
catch up with JC's amazing guy
creativity is the variable of success
all the strategies you create come to
the punchline this is a creative process
this show this content content is an is
a creative output and everything you
plan to that moment you can have the
greatest strategy ever to ask that girl
out right ever like planned out
everything but that moment where you go
in for the ask that content is the
variable possibly of a yes or no rain
there's other variables but you know
creativity is the absolute variable like
you might have understood that who
you're going after what to do when to
release that video game let's make it
Steve asked but if the graphics sucked
or the gameplay sucked or if it sucked
like creativity is the variable of
success in our society including things
that we don't have control of like if
you weren't just born gorgeous if you're
just a massively good-looking dude right
yeah your strategy might have sucked on
that a scout but your creativity not
creative maybe the word sucked but what
you said might have just been enough
like you're just a pretty boy you're
just pretty I mean you know how that is
Stefan I mean guys got no game but he
wins he's just pretty that's
yeah I mean luck that's that's real and
and you know it's funny actually using
looks and the way you spit game to girls
is actually a tremendous concept of
strategy and creativity like the way
ugly dudes get chicks is strategy and
and the creativity of their words and
charisma just the way it is I know and
so that's that statement of Nick give me
some statements this show was action
packed with a bunch of stuff happy New
Year to all of you that are celebrating
and I wish you a tremendous week
Indianapolis I'm coming to see ya you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
I had an ex-girlfriend that I dated in
2001 in 2002 text me yesterday she's
like with her family she's like I just
wanted to know something and change the
course of my life I don't know hardcore
Jets fan
[Music]